salut à tous bienvenue à Strasbourg dans
cette nouvelle édition d'Europe Hebdo
c'est parti pour 30 minutes d'actualité
européenne dans cette émission je vous
emmène à Naples en Italie depuis une
vingtaine d'années près de 10 millions
de tonnes de déchets industriels
toxiques ont été enfouis illégalement
dans la région les responsables sont
connus la Camorra la mafia napolitaine
qui a remporté de nombreux appels
d'offres publiques de retraitement des
déchets mais d'abord l'actualité le plan
de la Commission européenne sur les
migrations à peine dévoilées voilà les
polémiques notamment sur la question des
quotas de réfugiés alors l'Europe
manque-t-elle de solidarité c'est la
question de la semaine
il a fallu à peine quelques jours avant
que la polémique éclate mercredi la
Commission européenne présente enfin son
plan pour mieux gérer les migrations
triplement des fonds de l'agence fontex
programme de réinstallation de réfugiés
à l'échelle européenne opération de
démantèlement des réseaux de passeurs en
Méditerranée répartition temporaire des
demandeurs d'asile via des politiques de
quota en clair les 28 auront
l'obligation d'accueillir des réfugiés
en fonction de leur population leur
produit intérieur brut leur taux de
chômage la solidarité partagée selon les
termes de Jean-Claude Juncker président
de la Commission européenne une
révolution et là
David Cameron fraîchement réélu annonce
triomphalement que la Grande-Bretagne
refuse un système d'asile contraignante
Victor Orban Premier ministre hongrois
ne prend pas de pincettes nous ne
voulons pas d'immigrer chez nous
plus étonnant Manuel Valls non plus ne
veut pas de ses quotas la France fait
déjà beaucoup selon le Premier ministre
elle ne peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde alors la France liberté
égalité solidarité
la France ne peut pas accueillir toute
la misère du monde et l'Europe le
peut-elle c'est la question que je vais
poser à Edouard Martin bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous d'avoir Martin
alors on ne vous présente plus vous êtes
ici élu depuis presque un an maintenant
parce que
vous qui avez peut-être encore ce regard
de citoyen sur la manière dont la
politique européenne se déroule est-ce
que vous diriez que l'Europe manque de
solidarité et a fortiori la France
l'Europe oui effectivement manque de
solidarité et effectivement je suis
étonné du discours du premier ministre
français parce que la France est comme
le pays des droits de l'homme et c'est
aussi une terre d'asile mais on va pas
uniquement focaliser le débat autour de
la France et c'est l'Europe aujourd'hui
qui m'intéresse parce que l'Europe
aujourd'hui le Conseil a été affichu de
faire une proposition européenne de fin
avril après ça a été le conseil de la
honte ou il n'en ai rien ressorti et
après la mer Méditerranée qui est
devenue le cimetière des pauvres
migrants qui essaient de
fuir les guerres les violences etc et
bien c'est devenu la mère de la honte
puisque le Conseil a été incapable de
trouver une solution la proposition de
la Commission elle a au moins le mérite
d'exister effectivement on attendait
depuis longtemps on l'attendait depuis
longtemps et je pense que même si ça va
ça ne va pas assez loin yunker pose le
vrai débat c'est quel solidarité
l'Europe est-elle en capacité d'accepter
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que ce
sont les pays de sud de l'Europe qui
l'Italie l'Espagne janvier 39000
exactement je rappelle que l'Italie la
gestion des migrants c'est 9 millions et
demi d'euros chaque mois payés par
l'Italie donc on voit bien que l'esprit
de solidarité qui est le fondement même
de l'Europe ne joue pas et mais comme
vous voyez la France et a fortiori le
Premier ministre socialiste Manuel Valls
qui dit nous les quotas on en veut pas
et on veut pas on veut pas se voir
imposer en fait des des migrants et des
demandeurs d'asile en France finalement
c'est bien les chefs d'État et
gouvernement eux-mêmes la forteri le
chef d'État de gouvernement en France
François Hollande Manuel Valls qui
torpille la position de la Commission et
de ce propre Parlement tout à fait en
plus la Commission fait une proposition
effectivement ce ce qui la valideront ou
pas ce sont les chefs d'État les 28 donc
François Hollande là effectivement je
suis surpris de la position du Premier
ministre alors lorsqu'il dit je ne veux
pas de cottage je rappelle qu'on départ
c'est pas un terme qui a été utilisé
dans les propositions de la Commission
c'est de dire voilà comment à travers
une espèce de solidarité en chacun fait
des efforts pour accueillir pour faire
leur part de travail c'était ça l'idée
après si Manuel Valls a voulu dire je ne
veux pas de quotas c'est-à-dire que il
n'y a pas de seuil maximum parce que
après son fonction des besoins en
fonction de demande on est pris y
compris aller au-delà pourquoi pas mais
le fait de dire comme ça aussi
brutalement je ne veux pas de côté à la
France assez fait ça veut dire quoi que
la France est prête à laisser encore
mourir des milliers de personnes au-delà
mon point de vue alors je sais pas si
c'est le fait d'avoir
région PACA il était entouré de
Christian Estrosi
monsieur ti voilà donc
il y a pas à croire qu'on se l'entend
c'est ces deux personnages qui a une
espèce de noblesse de l'immigration donc
eux ce serait les nobles ou leurs
familles et puis les autres ne restent
pas le droit voilà les autres auraient
juste à droite c'est de mourir en
Méditerranée ça c'est inacceptable c'est
pas ça l'Europe de toute façon le fond
du problème c'est que aujourd'hui on est
en train de s'attaquer aux conséquences
de de de des migrants enfin de la des
des personnes qui essaient de fuir les
guerres les violences etc mais il faut
s'attaquer maintenant aux causes et bien
c'est ça le vrai débat alors justement
ça tombe bien que vous en parliez
puisque
il est discuté en ce moment une
proposition de règlement sur ce qu'on
appelle les minerais de sang
tantale tungstène est un or en gros
c'est minerait de sang beaucoup sont
extraits en République démocratique du
Congo et de nombreux groupes armés en
fait pillent ces ressources pour ensuite
aller les revendre et cela finance le
terrorisme enfin il y a quelques mois le
docteur Denis mogweguet était au sein de
ce Parlement et il avait tenu il venait
de recevoir le Prix Sakharov à l'époque
et il avait interpellé les
parlementaires lors de la réception de
ce prix je souhaiterais qu'on l'écoute
le projet de règlement européen de la
commission pour un approvisionnement
responsable un minerai qui doit être
examiné devant votre assemblée devrait
intégrer une dimension contraignante et
visée aussi bien les produits finis ici
à l'Occident que les matières premières
à l'état brut
en Afrique notre pays est plein de
potentiel et avec un commerce
responsable plus responsable et
transparent les Congo à la capacité d'un
développement endogène grâce à ces
ressources naturelles mais avant tout
ces ressources humaines qui ne peuvent
aujourd'hui être exploités pour les
bénéfices de tous dans un contexte de ni
P Niger monsieur le Président c'est
primora de signification pour les femmes
victimes de violence sexuelles que si
vous nous accompagnez sur les chemins de
la paix la justice et la démocratie
Edouard Martin les mots en fait du
docteur muqueguer sont extrêmement forts
on parle quand même de violences
sexuelles du viol comme comme arme de
guerre de meurtre exactement quel est le
rapport entre ces minerais ces
ressources naturelles qu'on retrouve
dans nos téléphones portables et ces
exactions et ses meurtres et ces viols
tout ça est lié et le lien avec la
politique migratoire je vais revenir
tout à l'heure le message très très
prégnant très poignant du docteur moukae
ou extrêmement forts
l'ensemble des 750 députés étaient
debout pour lui dire exactement il a été
ovation et là je suis en colère en
colère que voir qu'une partie j'espère
pas la majorité de ces parlementaires
sont prêts à tuer une deuxième fois
violer une deuxième fois parce que ils
n'ont pas écouté ce message il y a une
proposition que nous faisons nous c'est
de dire il faut la transparence la
traçabilité de l'ensemble des minerais
de sens c'est-à-dire que ce sont des
minerais qui sont extraits dans ces
pays-là et qui servent à travers une
économie parallèle à financer des bonnes
organisées des bandes armées qui
commettent des viols des meurtres etc et
donc on nous explique une partie des
parlementaires nous explique que non que
ça pourrait mettre en difficulté les
entreprises européennes on parle de
Apple de Microsoft en fait c'est ce
qu'on retrouve dans nos voitures dans
nos têtes
les éoliennes les ordinateurs etc tout
ce qui nous est indispensable à notre
économie donc ça veut dire que quelque
part et lorsque je vois la position du
Medef qui était là hier pour défendre
effectivement le fait qu'il faut surtout
pas énormément de lobbying sur cette
proposition de règlement c'est
scandaleux ils se disent socialement
responsable en même temps c'est à dire
que eux ont mis un prix sur la vie
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont estimé que la
vie d'un congolais d'une petite
congolaise qui se fait violer qui se
fait torturer vaut beaucoup moins cher
que une tonne de séminerait là donc il
faut continuer au nom de la
compétitivité à laisser faire le marché
laisser les multinationales financiers
de manière implicite les bonnes
organisées et bien c'est qu'en fait là
pour nous expliquer c'est que ce que
vous demandez dans ce règlement c'est de
tracer l'ensemble de la filière comme le
demander le docteur muque l'ensemble de
la filière l'ensemble des minerais de
des raffineries des fondeurs jusqu'au
transformateurs or la proposition que
nous est faite dans le rapport winter
c'est uniquement quatre métaux 4000 et
uniquement les raffineries et les
fonderies ça ne représente
ça ne représente que 5% des entreprises
de la filière ce sont les mêmes qui sont
victimes de ce harcèlement de ces
violences de ces barbaries qu'on
retrouve après sur les bateaux large de
Méditerranée et que nous refusons
d'accepter c'est à dire que on on leur
impose la double peine on ne fait rien
pour eux
on finance indirectement les bandes
armées et on le refuse asile donc ce
monde est devenu schizophrène c'est pas
possible et je tiens simplement à
souligner qu'en 2003 l'accord de
Kimberley a permis notamment grâce à la
traçabilité la transparence sur chercher
des diamants de mettre un terme à la
guerre Libéria on estime quand même
juste pour un chiffre que la guerre en
République démocratique du Congo c'est
déjà 3 millions et demi de morts quoi
donc c'est même plus que ça d'après les
ONG congolaises c'est 8 millions de
morts c'est des centaines de milliers de
femmes et même des bébés violets violets
et docteur mukweiger répare justement
les périls de sa vie péril de sa vie sa
vie est en danger évidemment rapidement
Édouard Martin on vous a confié la
rédaction d'un rapport sur l'industrie
durable alors je vais faire un peu ma
naïve dans cette histoire comment est-ce
que l'industrie vous l'ancienne la série
peut-être durable et peut-être je dirais
écologique
elle ne sera pas complètement écologique
à 100% c'est à dire qu'une industrie il
y aura toujours une part de pollution le
tout c'est comment on se donne on se
donne d'outils qui incite les
industriels à investir dans les
nouvelles technologies dans les énergies
propres dans le respect de la
l'environnement dans le respect de la
santé publique et c'est possible
beaucoup d'entreprises industrielles
industrialisées européenne le démontre
le seul problème c'est que l'Europe doit
imposer ces critères là aux industries
européennes mais elle doit aussi
l'imposer aux autres et nous sommes
aujourd'hui concurrencés notamment par
la par la Chine on sait bien ils n'ont
pas les mêmes règles que nous et c'est
ça ça crée de phénomènes on ne lutte pas
qu'autrement climatique et deuxièmement
il y a une concurrence déloyale qui met
à mal et nos emplois et nous industries
et ce que je propose vous l'avez vécu
vous-même exactement ce que je propose
et ça a été salué par beaucoup de mes
collègues parlementaires c'est de mettre
un ajustement carbone aux frontières de
l'Europe pour rééquilibrer tout ça c'est
une forme de taxe carbone
parce qu'une taxe c'est de l'argent qui
va aller dans la poche des états on ne
sait pas ce qu'ils vont en faire
l'ajustement carbone c'est quoi
aujourd'hui il existe un marché du
carbone au niveau européen ce sont les
entreprises les plus performantes qui
avec leur quotas les mettent les mettre
sur le marché il y a même une bourse
voilà et bien ces industriels qui ne
sont pas aux normes environnementales
européennes serait eux aussi obligé
d'acheter ces ce droit pollué sur le
marché européen et cet argent-là irait
de la poche et des industriels et avec
cet argent là il pourrait continuer des
investissements dans les énergies
propres de manière à être benchmark avec
les plus performants au niveau du
respect de l'environnement c'est ça
l'idée principale quand est-ce que vous
le rendez ce rapport il est finalisé il
est rendu aujourd'hui il sera soumur
vote au mois d'octobre bon bah écoutez
on suivra merci beaucoup de nous avoir
expliqué un petit peu tout ça nous on
continue direction l'Italie en
particulier Naples en 2008 éclate le
scandale de la Terre de Feu abasourdi
les Italiens découvrent que la Camorra
la mafia loc al a remporté de nombreuses
appels d'offres publiques et à défaut de
retraités les déchets les a enfouis
voire brûler à ciel ouvert reportage de
Louis civil
l'arrière pays de Naples la Campagna
Félix la compagnie bienheureuse depuis
quelques années ces terres fertile porte
un nouveau nom la Terre de Feu et pour
cause des montagnes de déchets brûlent
jour et nuit au milieu des champs et des
vergers
date de cette nuit comme vous pouvez le
voir il y a de tout pneus bouteilles de
solvant de vernis des déchets de
jardinage de goudron
s'il y a au mandat de contrôle il est
vraiment une mauvaise surveillance du
territoire ceux qui font ça le font
tranquillement en toute impunité pour
eux il n'y a aucun risque d'être arrêté
ou pris en flagrant délire
directement mais les responsables sont
connus ils ont même un nom la Camorra la
mafia
en vingt ans elle a réussi à tropter le
marché du traitement des déchets appel
d'offres truquées administrateur
corrompu et surtout tarif imbattable
jusqu'à 10 fois moins cher car la mafia
ne traite pas les déchets elle les brûle
ou les enfouis
de quoi gagner un très gros pactole près
de 30 milliards d'euros conséquence de
ces décharges illégales un impact
sanitaire désastreux Maora Messina est
une rescapée cette jeune italienne a été
atteinte d'une tumeur du sang très rare
les nappes phréatiques sont polluées
elle fait donc attention à tout ce
qu'elle boit
bon on utilise que cette eau qui est
filtré par une bande de l'eau communale
donc nous on y va on emporte les
bouteilles en plastique et en échange il
nous donne des bouteilles d'eau filtrées
maintenant guéri elle a créé un livre
pour témoigner
je savais que sur notre territoire il y
avait des décharges illégales et je
savais qu'il y avait des brasiers on en
avait entendu parler et on l'avait senti
et même vue à partir du moment où j'ai
commencé la chimiothérapie à la clinique
polyvalente j'ai rencontré énormément de
personnes qui habitaient ici même dans
ma rue comme moi et avait la même
pathologie que moi j'ai donc compris
qu'il y avait une forte corrélation
que ne fait pas l'État italien une étude
épidémiologique apportant été menée il y
aurait dans la région un taux de
mortalité de 10% supérieur à la moyenne
nationale ce docteur a remis plusieurs
expertises sur les déchets aux autorités
judiciaires de Naples selon lui ce qui
est avant tout révélateur c'est l'âge
des patients
des études ont démontré une augmentation
des tumeurs cérébrales chez les enfants
l'enfant n'est pas un sujet qui subit
les influences environnementales
ce qui est important c'est qu'on
constate une augmentation significative
non seulement des tumeurs cérébrales
mais aussi une augmentation des
malformations
est gagné par la psychose les marques
Barilla ou encore Findus n'achètent plus
de produits de la Terre de Feu
conséquences certains agriculteurs
n'arrivent plus à joindre les deux bouts
d'autres font du bio c'est le cas de
Nicolas tchétchéchere il possède 300
bufflonnes par chance son terrain n'a
pas été empoisonné elle a notre
particularité au-delà d'être bio c'est
qu'on a des bufflonnes qui vivent ici en
totale liberté son laser à faire de la
mozzarella il le revend à une
coopérative qui lutte contre la mafia
ici tous les agriculteurs ont vu la
caméra pourrir le sol certains ont même
du CD des terrains beaucoup se sont tu
de peur des représailles à la fois
complices et victimes on s'appelle nous
avons beaucoup souffert de cette
situation dans la Terre de Feu il y a eu
une baisse de la demande de mozzarella
et donc une répercussion directe sur le
prix du lait
la révélation de cette catastrophe
écologique et sanitaire a fait réagir
les gouvernements italiens
certains champs ont été mis sous
séquestre les outils techniques et
juridiques se sont étoffés mais c'est
encore insuffisant pour la procureur de
la région qui se confronte à la mafia
tous les jours
nous avons un problème en Italie c'est
que les délits sur l'environnement sont
punis par de simples contraventions
encore aujourd'hui et de ce fait il y a
prescription très rapidement
mais en ce moment le Parlement est en
train de valider une loi très importante
qui arrive enfin et qui punit avec des
peines beaucoup plus lourdes ce type de
crime
en juin dernier la ministre de la Santé
a promis 25 millions d'euros pour
permettre à la population de faire des
dépistages mais l'argent n'est toujours
pas arrivé 600 millions d'euros ont été
débloqués fin 2013 pour assainir
plusieurs sites à ce jour un seul et
dépollué
ironie du sort la dépollution devient
peu à peu un nouveau marché et la mafia
pourrait bien profiter de cette nouvelle
manne l'assainissement de sa propre
pollution
un Comblain de voir aujourd'hui à quel
point cette région de Naples a été
polluée par les faits et gestes de la
Camorra et pour en parler c'est Michel
rivazy que je reçois bonjour bonjour
Michel rivazy quand vous voyez cette
situation est-ce que ça vous étonne
finalement est-ce que c'est localisé à
l'Italie et à ce phénomène mafieux ou
est-ce qu'on voit ça ailleurs en Europe
on voit ça ailleurs en Europe le marché
des déchets c'est un marché colossal
rien qu'en Italie on vous parlait de 30
milliards d'euros ce que ça représente
et on s'aperçoit que il y a plein de
choses intéressantes dans votre portage
d'une part
tout ce qui touche à l'environnement
vous voyez que c'est que des amendes
donc les sanctions sont pas suffisantes
on voit que c'est effectivement
quelqu'un qui gère une des chats il met
n'importe quoi là il y a eu plus de 10
millions de tonnes de déchets mis en 20
ans avec pollution de l'air pollution de
l'eau et après problème sanitaire donc
ça coûte très très cher je dirais au
niveau des contribuables donc les
sanctions ne sont pas suffisantes parce
que quand on dit il faut décontaminer
mais la décontamination c'est le
principe pour l'ueur payeur il y a bien
des entreprises qui sont derrière ça et
ces entreprises qu'elles soient liées à
la maafia ou palier à la mafia elle
doivent payer et là en plus en Italie il
y a ce phénomène de mafia où la
Commission européenne avait mis en place
enfin le Parlement avait demandé une
commission spéciale cette nuit dans
l'ancienne législature oui et que on a
plus à l'heure actuelle donc il faudrait
absolument remettre de façon pérenne
parce que si on ne tue pas la mafia on
tue les gens dans ces dossiers on voit
bien qu'en fait là les représ en
politique les institutions publiques ne
sont pas à la hauteur des enjeux je
dirais même que il y a une corruption
latente et acceptée parce que comment on
peut m'expliquer que ça soit dans votre
reportage ou que ça soit chez nous parce
que il y a eu bagnoles bagnoles en forêt
dans le Var il y a eu il y a énormément
d'échanges qui sont illégales c'est
décharger les gars il y en a ils sont
légales mais elles ont un fonctionnement
illégal et chaque fois des mers ou des
associations attaquent mais on dirait
que on n'a pas envie de savoir parce que
quand dans une décharge on met des
déchets toxiques où on met des déchets
qui ne devraient pas y être on pourrait
augmenter les contrôles en diminuant les
contrôles ces gens continuent à le faire
ils se font de l'argent sur le dos des
contribuables des entreprises et on a
une justice qui ne sanctionne pas assez
oui parce que il faut savoir que c'est
toxiques polluent les sols les nappes
phréatiques et qu'on se retrouve avec
des questions sanitaires comme c'est
exactement et ça c'est un coup pour la
société donc il faut nous en tant que
député européen vous voyez il y a des
directives sur les déchets on demande à
ce que ça soit recyclables on demande à
ce que on diminue les déchets etc etc
mais comme ça coûte cher pour les
entreprises et bien il y a des gens qui
utilisent ça pour dire on vous achète
vos déchets pendant 250 € la tonne en
Europe et vous allez en Somalie ou
ailleurs c'est 2,5 euros la Todd donc la
marche pour eux la marge est pour eux et
en plus en Somalie ce qu'il y avait s'il
y avait un trafic d'armes derrière c'est
à dire donc là en fait ce que vous nous
expliquez c'est que on peut bien essayer
de légiférer en Europe parce que la
plupart de enfin le Parlement le Conseil
et la Commission ont fait notamment sur
les déchets toxiques mais que on est
face à une mafia kettle et qui de
surcroît mondialisée que en gros ça sert
à rien non ça sert pas à rien moi je
pense que c'est très bien de légiférer
on a besoin de réglementation mais il
faut que le contrôle soit de père
c'est-à-dire que on investisse dans le
contrôle or le contrôle c'est dû aux
États membres donc comme il y a une
restriction du qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
réduit le contrôle oui j'imagine que là
dans le cas de l'Italie il y a aussi de
la corruption dans le dans les
organismes contrôle mais il y a une
corruption dans tous les maillons mais
c'est là où il faut être draconi en
disant pollueur-payeur mais le pollueur
payeur c'est aussi toute la chaîne qui
est complice donc s'il y a un contrôle
et une justice qui si vous voulez taxe
sanctionne davantage les pollueurs et
ben on diminuera ça et puis je dirais
aussi au niveau des consommateurs c'est
que il y aura toujours des déchets mais
il faut absolument diminuer les déchets
si on ne voyait on est toujours en fuite
en avant à consommer autrement il faut
apprendre aussi à ce que les entreprises
nous fassent pas des emballages des
trucs ou des déchets de plus en plus
toxiques vous voyez quand on parle
d'écologie circulaire il faut absolument
que ça soit global mais il faut des
sanctions et puis il faut protéger les
journalistes il faut protéger les juges
en Italie le juge est mort alors on dit
que c'est un accident mais de plus en
plus de gens pensent que c'est plutôt un
attentat et et vous voyez que si on
continue dans ce sens là
le pourrissement de la société sera
telle que les gens ne sont plus protégés
et c'est votre santé et là on la voit
bien alors il y avait un des
intervenants du reportage qui avait une
question directe à vous poser je
souhaiterais qu'on écoute
du moment que le problème est bien la
mauvaise gestion des déchir urbains en
compagnie en Europe mais aussi et
surtout sur industriel la question est
quel est votre implication pour faire
une loi de traçabilité et une robe des
déchets industriels et qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de notre proposition de
mettre des puces de qualité sur tous les
produits italiens mais aussi européens
qui seraient prise en charge par
l'entreprise et qui serait la
certification de la provenance du
produit à tout
aylanzi a dit contrôle de la provinine
ça delprodote
Michel riasi mais moi je trouve que
c'est une bonne proposition la
traçabilité en fait c'est de dire tous
les déchets toxiques et bien il faut
qu'il soit tracé pour que on sache d'où
ça vient et qu'on puisse sanctionner
mais je suis j'ai envie de lui dire mais
écoutez voter au Parlement européen des
gens qui sont pour la protection et pour
l'intérêt général regardez on va voter
aujourd'hui sur les minerais qui
proviennent de zones de conflit on en a
parlé avec Edward Martin et bien là il y
a plein de gens les conservateurs et les
libéraux qui ne veulent pas que ça soit
obligatoire parce que c'est ça aussi la
traçabilité voyez des minerais qui
viennent de région où il y a échange de
minerais contre des armes et bien si la
majorité du Parlement veut pas voter la
traçabilité comment il va voter la
traçabilité des déchets donc ça veut
dire que quand vous choisissez vos élus
choisissez des élus qui soit pour
l'intérêt général et non pas pour la
déréglementation en faisant en sorte que
des entreprises utilisent des
entreprises mafieuses pour gérer déchets
moi dernièrement ce qui m'a offusqué
c'est que en Italie par exemple il y a
eu plus de 180 cargos qui transportaient
des déchets radioactifs des déchets
toxiques chimiques que on fait exploser
en pleine mer mais vous vous rendez
compte dans quel monde c'est après la
même mais là le problème c'est qu'on a
des bombes écologiques et il existe dans
certains pays des délits en fait de
pollution comment se fait-il en fait
qu'au niveau européen on n'est pas créé
cette espèce de d'espace globale ou là
on aurait là législation et l'organisme
contrôle et bien c'est pour ça qu'on
veut créer un procureur européen et que
tous ces crimes ça soit des crimes
contre l'humanité vous voyez on le fait
sur les droits de l'homme qu'on fait ce
tribunal international et bien il faut
que l'environnement à l'heure actuelle
ça soit considéré comme un crime contre
l'humanité avec un procureur voyez qu'il
soit à l'échelle européenne et qui est
la capacité de prendre la capacité le
problème de manière globale exactement
on voit bien que là c'est saucisson est
quand même voyez la commission qu'elle a
fait elle a attaqué la Grèce et l'Italie
elle aura la Cour de justice européenne
a demandé 40 millions justement contre
l'Italie et 20 millions contre la Grèce
pour mauvaise gestion des déchets mais
c'est encore pas suffisant puisque ça
continue donc il faut que les gens
soient vraiment attaqués en disant vous
êtes mafieux c'est scandaleux que vous
avez fait vous devez rembourser ou vous
êtes en prison en perpétuité c'est pas
possible de laisser ce laxisme parce que
notre génération on subit des
conséquences vous avez vu cette femme
qui a eu des leucémies
et puis nous ça va continuer mais bien
sûr ça va continuer par l'intérieur de
la mer parce qu'il y aura on va
retrouver des produits
exactement et donc ça veut dire que tous
les échelons ont une responsabilité et
c'est que par la sanction qui
comprendront que ils sont responsables
et donc coupables Michel rivazy merci
est-ce que vous connaissez le magazine
Phosphore oui le magazine Phosphore donc
il s'adresse au lycée enfin les années
lycées alors on est plutôt content de
vous présenter le premier webdoc en fait
de phosphore.com qui est en ligne à
partir d'aujourd'hui réalisé par Estelle
forêt et emmaoulin figurez-vous qu'elles
ont été à la rencontre de jeunes dans
toute l'Europe qui entre 17 et 19 ans en
Allemagne en Bulgarie au Royaume-Uni en
Bosnie voilà donc un super doc qui
s'appelle la dream team dont le
l'adresse s'affiche en ce moment donc on
vous invite à aller le voir merci
beaucoup Michel rivazine de nous avoir
expliqué tout ça nous c'est terminé pour
cette semaine rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine avec Katia à Bruxelles bonne
suite de programme Ciao